internet and citizens of the reject
Nation welcome to the list I was most
afraid to make with Black Adam now in
theaters it is time to rank the entire
DC film Universe after and including Man
of Steel now this list is going to
include the Joker and the Batman even
though those are not part of the DC EU
the Multiverse they're not tied together
but we wanted to include them because I
love those movies so they're all
included here but things like Peacemaker
are not even though it's a direct
spin-off of The Suicide Squad if we
start including shows this is a four
hour video and Greg will be very upset
that being said if you want to see any
other lists or rankings leave a comment
below let me know what your rankings of
this video are I'm curious what your 15
is of these DC films how you would rank
them and you want to see me making
anything else you want to see some Fan
cast you want to see uh some breakdowns
of my favorite fights my favorite
costumes my favorite villains whatever
it is you want to see let me know in the
comments below and please do follow me
on Tick Tock where you can see shorter
versions of those videos we got 10
seconds we have 15 seconds we got three
minutes we got all sorts of links of of
comic book goodness over at koi johndro
but in the meantime I'm scared because
the DC fans are lovely but passionate
let's get into it
kicking it off with Suicide Squad now I
am a huge David Ayer fan and that
actually might be part of what makes
this so low on the list is I had really
high expectations they did an incredible
job painting a picture of a movie they
didn't actually make and that's not
David ayer's fault he made a movie and
then a another tractor made a giant
movie called Guardians of the Galaxy and
then the studio decided they wanted
something more akin to that so cut a
trailer to make you feel like you got
that movie and then it went through all
sorts of rewrites and retoolings and all
these things making a movie frankly it
wasn't and it feels like it that's an
issue yes I would love to see the air
cut one day yes I would love to see what
David Ayer would do with the suicide
squad and yes I do see the irony that
then years later The Suicide Squad with
the original director of Guardians of
the Galaxy did in fact make a movie I
love very much but for this cut of this
movie I think the movie that suffered
the most from Studio interference and a
lot of hooks in the kitchen is Suicide
Squad so something had to be the lowest
it's going to be Suicide Squad coming in
at number 14 is Batman vs Superman dawn
of Justice the theatrical cut this movie
in itself I have talked about at length
with passion and hope in the worst comic
book movie list on this very channel
it's just my opinion it is one of the
ones that that I think I suffered most
through and even the title it's Batman v
Superman that's law that's when is
Batman suing Superman I don't understand
some of the fundamentals of this movie
and it didn't help that it got truncated
down to a two-hour experience when the
other cut is much more fleshed out it's
a different experience this cut of the
movie made me feel like it disrespected
Superman and not understanding the
character as I've always read them again
this is my personal opinion that's why
it's my opinion list and Batman didn't
feel like Batman to me as much as Ben
Affleck is perfect I think Ben Affleck
as Batman as one of the greatest casting
choices of all time I think Henry Cavill
is Superman is one of the greatest
casting choices of all time so it pains
me when they're under the direction of
someone as talented as Zack Snyder that
so much can go wrong and that's all I
feel like this is I love all of the
pieces of this puzzle the puzzle just
did not work for me and I feel like it
tried to do way too much this was just
be vs great if it was just doomsday
great but it tries to be a junior
Justice League movie in two hours it's
not for me coming in at number 13 is
Justice League AKA Justice League this
is the Joss Whedon cut of Justice League
I didn't even realize when assembling
this list that there are so many cuts
that I have to like explain on the
journey into the movie which version
we're discussing but the Joss Whedon cut
of Justice League did have a couple
scenes that I did feel were very
authentic to the character it did a lot
wrong that is why it's so low I'm not
defending this movie but I do find
there's certain flash scenes and there's
certain moments that did sing for the
characters and there's certain back and
forth dialogue that worked but man
that's the best thing I can find this
movie was very rushed this movie didn't
make a lot of sense there were moments
that happened seemingly out of nowhere
there were things that just occurred and
none of it felt like it was rewarding or
had weight behind it it just felt like I
was watching a cartoon in a bad way
ironically some of the best ever
adaptations from DC are cartoons and
this one one felt like a bad cartoon and
let's not even get started on the CGI of
the mustache and the journey from page
to screen this one just inherently felt
flawed and I couldn't stop thinking that
when watching it number 13. all right
we're gonna get a little bit into the
weeds here with Wonder Woman 84 because
I don't know what this movie might have
been without coven I always try to give
a little little asterisks but overall
this was one of the biggest
disappointments for me from first movie
to sequel maybe ever we live in an age
where sequels are actually good people
don't talk about like oh it's a sequel
and and have that certain tone of oh I'm
worried like you did in the 80s 70s even
some of the 90s sequels weren't good
this felt like that where they just
tried to go bigger they just tried to go
Bolder they just tried to go more Brazen
but without the heart the thing that
made Wonder Woman so special is that
Patty Jenkins and Gal Gadot felt like
they understood what was so important
about Wonder Woman this one I feel like
it was very shiny and I feel like a lot
of the things that sang didn't sing as
well here I love the Chris Pine Gal
Gadot dynamic they made it a very very
weird subplot that did not feel
comfortable throughout the film The
Villain somehow didn't work and that's
one of the best casting choices you
could have gotten for that 80s Tony
Robbins big flavor and also the logic of
the movie I still don't know why it was
set then I still don't feel connected to
the story and then the third act just
felt like a mess I like what it tried to
do but I don't think it did it and it's
one of my bigger disappointments of
comic book movies all right things are
getting better we got Batman vs Superman
Ultimate Edition this is that girthy
three hour cut this is the experience
this movie had a lot right this movie
added some to Lex Luthor that made it
feel a bit more like Lex Luthor to me
this added some elements that fleshed
out Batman and Superman enough that it
felt more warranted that they had some
animosity I still maintained that there
are things that work in the comics that
do not work in movies when you read a
comic book your imagination is doing 90
of the work when you read a comic book a
character in 2D fighting another
character in 2D that are both drawings
and visual representations of deities
you can and believe more fully that a
human being that has billions of dollars
could fight a god alien a little more
plausibly because of the media and yes
just because it happened in the comic
doesn't mean it should necessarily
happen in the movie world because that's
a director giving you his vision in a
world that's 3D that feels more tangible
your brain when you watch a movie goes
hey that could happen I'm living as
someone in this world that's different
than a comic and I think that's the
biggest flaw from the entire concept of
Batman vs Superman I like it as an idea
I like it as a comic I don't necessarily
like it as a movie because when I see
Batman being like I don't like this and
fighting a God I don't buy it he's one
of the smartest men in the world he's
the world's greatest detective he
wouldn't throw a punch at an alien that
could smear him across the planet in two
seconds that fundamental does make it
hard for me to like this movie but I did
enjoy it for what it was and I'm very
glad the ultimate edition exists still
not one of my favorite movies but a vast
improvement over the original cut all
right it's time to talk about Bongo
squids I enjoyed moments of Aquaman
because there were so many moments that
felt like burning man there were so many
moments that felt otherworldly there
were so many moments that immersed me
much the way Avatar did but then there
were other mode this movie is a very
interesting like 50 50 experience where
overall I walked out with like a nice
solid B feeling I I really enjoyed the
overall but when I think of my
experience in the movie there are large
gaps of interest that said there are
great performances in here I really
think that some of the best acting from
villains happens in here for example
Patrick Wilson somehow makes that
character work while wearing that
throughout throughout the movie I wasn't
bothered by Jason momoa's take on
Aquaman which feels very counter to my
belief in what Aquaman is you'll notice
a lot of my reviews deal with how I
believe these characters and
archetypally presented this to me isn't
the Aquaman archetype but the conviction
was there the world they built around
Jason momoa's Aquaman was there and the
belief in the villain and the and the
Very maniacal mustache rolling subplot
all really worked so the reason it's so
low is the gaps in moments of
believability and the moments were it
dragged but there's a reason it made a
billion dollars this movie's bananas I
like that they let it get full weird I
really hope the sequel is just as
octopus drum heavy did you say
Place Amber Heard I will sign the
petition to not comment
all right now we're into the goodons the
ones I really enjoy the ones I
re-watched the ones I experienced as a
comic book fan and really love that they
exist and that is going to be one of my
favorite movies of the year it came out
and one of the movies that surprised me
most frankly the Snyder cut of justice
league isn't quite a movie and it was
actually tricky I knew I had to include
it on here because that's what all the
comments would be but this is a four
hour experience this is almost a show
this is something I would have loved to
see in theaters because this is the run
time of many seasons of Television that
I enjoy and it's the first thing the
very first thing that made me feel like
Zack Snyder's view of superheroes was
possible I did feel that sense of Marvel
underdogs they're with us on our level
they're fighting alongside us up at Gods
DC they're Gods looking down they're
trying to figure out how to live
alongside us they're these deities
they're these experiences that we're
reacting and responding to those are two
very different tones and sometimes the
comics do refer reflect those it's not
as black and white as that but this felt
like that this felt like the world I
always saw Zack Snyder encountering of
these characters and when it's so so
passionate and when it's full of so much
conviction and when it believes itself
so much I believe it regardless of my
view of these characters because I'm
watching someone else's belief in these
characters that is so strong I'm in that
was this movie I believed every moment I
had conviction I was enamored and it's
what I wanted from the beginning of Man
of Steel to see in his world and I think
it delivered I'm ever so impressed with
the Snyder cup and here we are at the
reason for this list and the movie that
really impressed me we're at Black Adam
now Black Adam does something that I've
seen many many comic book movies attempt
to do and that's deal with an anti-hero
but when you've got an anti-hero in a
movie you usually have a character
that's just like I'm grumpy or I believe
that you should hit them harder uh you
don't often get a true anti-hero
sometimes you get something like the
Punisher but that takes a show the
reason that Jon bernthal's Punisher
feels so believable is you got time to
immerse yourself in his belief system
that's really hard to do in two hours
what I was most impressed by in Black
Adam is that I felt equally for the
Justice Society of America who I just
met and I always say it's hard to
establish a team in one movie and Black
Adam himself which is the most
charismatic man in entertainment the
rock it is hard to believe anyone going
up against The Rock there's a reason
he's always the lead is like yeah I'm
rooting for the rock I was rooting for
both sides of this very tricky
conversation in a world where there are
superheroes and gods what do you do when
you keep having villains get back up do
you kill is killing acceptable for the
greater good I loved this take on
anti-heroes I loved how much it trusted
the audience I loved that I was
immediately invested in Hawkman and Dr
Fate I love that throughout the movie I
was wondering where I aligned on the
side of anti-heroes and I love this new
stoic take from The Rock I thought the
rock really delivered a different
version of The Rock everyone critiques
his like oh he's the rock in every movie
this wasn't that performance and it felt
like Black Adam is a man that was
dedicated to a role for 15 years and it
showed and to me this movie Not only did
the Black Adam story Justice it did
anti-heroes Justice and I'm very excited
for where the hierarchy of power goes
next are you ready for the comments are
you ready Greg are you ready
that's just for you that's for the SEO
the comments to drive this kind of
trending and what do I like even more
than Black Adam the original Man of
Steel a movie I have wanted a sequel to
for the better part of what is it 15
years now this one is very tricky for me
because I have always seen and enjoyed
Superman as a Boy Scout I have always
appreciated that much like Captain
America when done right I feel for a
character that should be boring I don't
necessarily think on paper these
characters work but when translated they
sing I love Henry cavill's take on
Superman I don't necessarily love how
it's utilized throughout this film it
works a lot of the time but not all the
time the reason it's not higher is there
are moments where I'm like that doesn't
feel like Superman to me even though I
believe in Henry cavill's Superman I
don't love the death of Jonathan Kent I
don't love and this might be me
retroactively plugging it in the Martha
stuff to come later because of the
interaction with Batman I know I said
the the the curse word of the DC filmed
universe but the stuff that comes later
does feel like it kind of undermines my
experience with what this was building
to this movie itself excellent taught
action thriller a genius way to make us
feel like God's walk amongst us some of
the most beautiful visuals in comic book
film but if I don't always feel like
it's authentic to the character even for
a few scenes that does put it lower than
the top five I love Man of Steel but it
can't be as high as some of the other
ones I feel like stay true to what I
believe these characters are and in
addition to it being a great top
thriller the action establishes a world
where you do believe a man is faster
than a speeding bullet more powerful
than a locomotive it does establish a
greater DC filmed universe and there's a
reason Zack Snyder became the architect
for so much to come starting with this
movie it is one of the most visually
stunning experiences in superheroom
alright this is where I imagine things
are going to start to get spicy I'm
gonna go with a movie that really really
wrecked me in theaters I had a very
interesting experience with this film
where I finished it and was like that's
a dangerous movie I don't think that
often I think this is a movie that
emboldens Allah lot of the wrong people
I think this is a movie that will be
misinterpreted by the wrong people I
think much like my favorite movie of all
time it has the worst inherent PR and
that is the Joker my favorite movie of
all time is Fight Club I think a lot of
people don't realize Tyler durden's the
antagonist I think a lot of people don't
realize that it was written by a very
frustrated gay man about toxic
masculinity I think a lot of people that
use the word snowflake don't realize it
came from Fight Club to make fun of the
people that now wield it I think the
Joker is the same I think this is a
movie that is a deep satire that when
activating the wrong people that see the
joker as their hero are going to be
misled I think this movie absolutely
nailed what it's like to feel trapped in
a system I think this movie absolutely
nailed what it's like to feel alone and
put out and left to rot and to be
removed from society I think this movie
did some of the best else world work
I've ever seen this isn't the Joker of
the Batman lore Bruce Wayne's child this
isn't the Joker that does what he does
in the animated series or even the other
movies this is an else world where we've
got a stand-up comedian take on the
Joker that is just broken and rotten
through and through and the reason I
love this movie so much is that I felt
for him and that scared the [ __ ] out of
me I felt for every choice he made I
felt for every decision he did and that
worried me about how far we can slip and
how easily I think this movie has some
flaws in its Exposition I think this
movie has some flaws in how it's a
little heavy-handed but I think overall
it's [ __ ] magic uh that this movie
can be made and you could take these
bull chances and and everything that it
delivered I really really think the
Joker is a very special experience all
right we're into the top five and the
movie that's gonna get me the most crap
on this whole list because I love it so
so so very much a movie with Incredible
action as stunt directed by the team
behind John Wick a movie that
establishes an entire team in one movie
that makes you believe hey you can do
team movies in one go a movie with one
of the most usually appealing gothams I
have ever seen that somehow matches the
Nolan realism with the insanity of a
Joel Schumacher circus Gotham it somehow
Blends those two and makes this stunning
bit of art a movie that is colorful like
a comic book that is shot like a comic
book that is big as a comic book a movie
with maybe my favorite DC villain who is
a complete reinterpretation from the
comic who is able to be both malicious
and hilarious in Gotham the villains are
terrifying but you're also Charmed by
them this is the most I've seen that and
it's Ewan McGregor having the best time
of his life as black mask in addition to
five incredible heroines in Harley Quinn
and the emancipation of birds of prey I
don't remember the title that's not a
good sign for the top five What's the
title of this movie
fabulous emancipation of Harley Quinn
number five is the birds afraid the
fantabulous emancipation of one Harley
Quinn I think Margot Robbie really truly
loves this character and I think it
shows whether it's that incredible
sandwich scene or the fights with the
hammer later on or it's the circus
Madness you get in the third act I also
think Mary Elizabeth Winstead is one of
the most slept on performances in this
movie and that's a spin-off I would want
I am we're getting that Black Canary
spin-off with journey Smollett hopefully
I hope it still happens there are so
many pieces to this that have to nail it
to add up to the great tapestry that is
this movie this is like starting with a
Justice League movie at the jump this is
a team movie with the lead we already
love and she doesn't feel outshined and
they don't feel outshined and the
villain again one of the best villains I
think in DC doesn't outshine anyone that
is so impressive I think this movie is
one of the most comic accurate in its
sensibilities in that it's a blast and
it's colorful but it lets itself be
brutal and it's also a great commentary
on real life you get so many moments of
emotional impact while you have this
incredible cacophony of Sight and Sound
I love birds of prey this movie is not
appreciated enough all right we're up to
the suicide squad James Gunn Take On The
Suicide Squad is a masterpiece this
movie from start to finish does not let
us the gas this movie is Full Tilt
insanity this is what you can do with an
R-rated movie this is going to be a take
that will get all the the stupid rivalry
that doesn't exist there is no Marvel vs
DC rivalry except what you make at Jeff
Jones and Kevin feige your friends but
this statement I stand by but I don't
mean for it to cause fighting I'm just
saying it this is what I want from
letting directors do their thing within
the universe but still untethered that I
think they were doing with phase four
that didn't land as well I think this is
exactly what you need to do in having a
greater universe but also letting a
director make their movie I think a big
problem I have Multiverse of Madness was
it didn't feel like it was in the MCU as
much fun as it was a Sam Raimi movie I
think a big problem I had with love and
Thunders that felt like a tiger movie
but didn't feel like it knew the
characters that it was playing with
anymore this does both this is able to
balance the greater DC Universe this is
able to make all the characters
interesting and important and it's able
to let James Gunn make effectively a 200
million dollar trauma film this movie is
balls to the wall crazy and it launched
Peacemaker which by the way would land
right in front of this as far as if we
were including shows it is so special so
unique the fact that you feel for polka
dot man a character that shouldn't even
get the time of day the fact that they
let David dust mulchin play with that
amount of emotionality and pause in
those scenes the fact that Harley Quinn
got that incredible stunt sequence that
that the crazy walk and talk but with
violence the fact that we are so
invested in two sides of the same
violent vigilante coin with Idris Elba
and John Cena and that's just off the
top of my head a few of the characters
this whole experience is so rat catcher
you care about a character called rat
catcher you love a character called rat
catcher this is why we love comic books
because you feel for characters that
feel like Outsiders that feel impossible
and yet you feel with and for them James
Gunn gets Outsiders maybe more than
anyone and he makes you feel for king
shark just as much as he made you feel
for Rocket Raccoon he he has you for two
hours and it's bananas and it surprised
you at every turn I I love what this
movie accomplished it's so much fun
number three and this one is a tricky
dance with what I just did with number
four I was really debating between the
suicide squad and Wonder Woman but I
think what Wonder Woman had to do was
harder and that is is really interesting
to say because all the characters in The
Suicide Squad aren't beloved and that is
the strength of the freedom but Wonder
Woman is beloved and she hasn't had the
big spectacle release there's a reason
they canceled so many Wonder Woman
properties there's a reason you have to
hit the tone just right I think this did
The Impossible and it nailed the tone I
wanted Superman to it nailed what this
character means in and out of universe
you look at Wonder Woman and you feel
presence you feel this sense of wonder
you feel this incredible Aura of what it
is to be from themaskara what it is to
look up to Wonder Woman her choreography
is Top Notch I love the they made a new
fighting style the sliding around the
using the z-axis the choreography with
the bands the scene of No Man's Land is
amongst the greatest scenes in comic
book movies and then the scene of the
two of them on the ship with Chris Pine
and galgonaut just talking about the
rules of the world they're basically
giving you Exposition but it's so
charming and so endearing that you fall
in love with both of them so it's able
to do the rom-com thing the action thing
and Be An Origin movie it is so special
I feel like with time people have kind
of Forgotten what it was like to first
see this and the and the junkie XL score
the sound of Wonder Woman is so powerful
I love her theme this movie was so great
I do completely own the third act falls
apart I love it thematically but
visually it did not work for me the
video game third act did not sing but I
love thematically what it represented
and that's enough for me to just
slightly Edge out the suicide squad
depending on my mood this might be
number four that might be number three
but especially because of the third act
but the second act with no man's land
the First Act with the boat scene of
them talking the World building
everything else far outweighs my dislike
for that third and the fact that I felt
so much for everyone so immediately I
think Wonder Woman is what I want to
show my children like it's a movie that
I want to impart uh Wonder with and
number two now this one's personal every
time there's a movie that addresses
adoption or foster children or those
things it's usually done like
maliciously like you don't think of
foster houses as you know a positive
thing and I'm not a foster child but I
know a lot of people that came up
through the system I have a lot of
friends that have been hard on their
luck and out in the street and it is
really really special to see a Superhero
Movie see the world of taking people in
his family this directly almost every
superhero movie has something to do with
family much like the Fast and Furious
film and this one deals with a different
kind of family and grows it out and you
feel every beat of this this movie felt
like the best of amblin to me it had
that 80s warmth with that almost too
dark action to be not rated R with the
sense of fear of like The Goonies and
Gremlins like that amazing 80s feeling
in a superhero film and then you add the
charm of what Zach Levi is able to do as
a giant man child because Zach Levi is
like the king of Comic-Con he's been one
of us for so long and you feel that in
every frame then you've got the
incredible performances by Asher angel
with his mom Jack Dylan Grazer being one
of the best Sidekicks I've ever seen the
playfulness the sarcastic the sense of
Boyhood smarm that we all went through
if you you know we're a Boyhood smarty
boy like I was there's so much right in
this movie and then Mark Strong is the
villain I love the end where the family
literally levels up and becomes a shoe's
family after you've fallen in love with
all of them I love the casting choices I
love the unknowns I didn't know these
foster parents and I loved them so
dearly I thought the action was
top-notch I love that it's set at
Christmas I I think when I read a comic
as a trade like a whole Arc if I can
finish it and get the same sense of
warmth and wonder and moral compass and
feeling connected to the world that I
get from Shazam that is one of my top
comics so that this movie which I did
not have a lot of expectations for came
out out and bowled me over I think it
really established itself as a hard
thing to top I wasn't looking forward to
Shazam and then it became my number two
DC film it's it's I would change nothing
it's Pitch Perfect number one for Batman
no number one is the Batman because it
is the David Fincher comic book movie I
always dreamed of I am a huge fan of
Matt Reeves I think everything he's done
is a market change in that climate in
filmmaking David Fincher to me is my
favorite director he's someone that
literally when he makes a movie I'm
there night one I study it I experience
it I can't wait to read what people
analyze from it Matt Reeves to me made a
love letter to David Fincher with my
favorite DC character he made the Batman
I've always wanted he made him street
level he made him a detective he made
him give a [ __ ] he made him someone that
felt modern but Timeless this is a
character that can be so many different
things I love that we've had Michael
Keaton's Batman I love that we've had
Chris Nolan's Christian Bale Batman that
felt so completely different I love that
simultaneously to Robert Pattinson's
Batman we had Ben Affleck running around
Ben Affleck is the Frank Miller Bruiser
of the Batman Robert Pattinson is the
kid just coming up he's here too he's
Scott Snyder's Batman from the comic
books he's someone one figuring it out
that is so invested that he's lost in it
I love how lost he is in this the
Nirvana play is genius the Leaning into
the slight emo sensibilities this is a
dude that identifies with bats that
lives in a cave who's only friends as a
butler like these are recluse I love
that they committed all of that to me
the commentary on what Gotham would be
now is fascinating if you look at Chris
Nolan's Batman which is to me the
standard the thing I didn't love was
that Gotham felt like it was very
established in the first one and by the
time we got to the third one it was an
actual character I didn't feel like I
could visit Gotham I feel like I could
visit Gotham in this world I feel like
it's places in America right now and I
feel like the crime that's happening in
it could happen right now and I feel
like the injustices people felt that
turned villains the entire Cadre of
Riddlers those people feel the
injustices of the world today that felt
like a documentary of what we deal with
online that felt like a documentary of
people that feel like they've been
pushed out so while Shazam welcomed
people in and made you feel like a
family everyone including the Riddler
himself felt like they got pushed out
and what do you do when Society kicks
you out things like the Joker that movie
things like the Batman with the Riddler
all of those things this is basically
two sides of the same coin one person
felt like he was outside of society but
had the money to make choices the other
person felt like he was out to the
society and didn't have anything else he
could do except destroy it I love that
Duality I love that this felt tangible I
love the [ __ ] chase scene with the
penguin I didn't get to the casting
Colin Farrell is the Penguin Jeffrey
Wright as Commissioner Gordon the first
time I ever believed Commissioner Gordon
Batman relationship to that level
everything about this movie and then
leaning back watching it and letting it
wash over you I watched this three times
in theaters the first week came out
because I loved living in it I love this
[ __ ] movie actually it's a detective
Gordon
oh that's why I believed it because I
don't believe commissioner I believe
detective Gordon and Batman's really
that that's accurate that's accurate I
cannot wait to watch the Batman again
so that is my list those are the 15 DC
films we've had since the Man of Steel
effective reboot of whatever you want to
call it the DC EU the DC films all in
honor of Black Adam which is now playing
which I enjoyed the [ __ ] out of I really
really really really really am curious
how this list goes over because one of
the coolest things about the DC film
universe is that it is so varied Birds
of Prey feels very different from the
Snyder cut and the Joker feels very
different from Shazam that means there
are so many different people that
identify with different corners of it
but that doesn't mean anyone's wrong my
list is going to be different than your
list because I've lived 34 different
years than you have please in the
comments let me know what your
experience of these films were let me
know what you identified with these
characters let me know what you enjoyed
let me know what your 15 is and let me
know in the comments what else what else
you'd want to see do you want to see me
ranking villains do you want to see my
26 through 50. Craig's loving that head
shake I'm getting out of him you want to
see uh maybe favorite fight scenes let
me know any ideas you guys have I will
see you all very very soon let me know
what you want to see next so much love
of reject Nation we'll see you soon no
love for the Batgirl movie huh well you
know having not seen it
[Music]